yeah good afternoon Sasha this is around
this intersection are already feeling
the construction panes but on tomorrow
morning it's supposed to get a whole lot
worse Monday morning through the entire
week this intersection will be closed to
all traffic has businesses like
capriata's truck preparing for more
online orders as people try to avoid the
construction for employees they're even
planning their routes ahead of time come
the back way through Maryland Parkway
from Sahara they can get through us
because they can just turn in if they go
this way I don't know how they're going
to get through
she says it won't deter their loyal
customers from coming in but they are
looking forward to the Project's
completion this 51 million dollar
project will install new storm drains to
help alleviate the heavy flow of storm
water that flow down the street surface
of Charleston Boulevard in the past now
the completion of this entire project is
expected in 2024 as for the intersection
behind me that should be done in time
for Memorial Day weekend reporting in
downtown Las Vegas Brian will 8 News Now